hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go
subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley put your [ __ ] seat belts on
we're putting it in first gear
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is ru garbage god damn it it's a
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians
and find out if they go up classy or if
they're absolute trash
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful day down here
chilly day aunt toddy's basement she's
out bowling
which i've learned as code for stealing
amazon packages
might be a couple of new neck pillows or
cutting boards
floating around the studio i like it
thank you buddy my co-host is coming at
you from right next to me the most
positive thing i think he's ever said to
me he said he liked it
this guy i'm all warm and fuzzy he's the
[ __ ] ceo of are you garbage
he keeps us one step ahead of the
federal investigative units
kevin james ryan everybody let's make
sure
his name make sure donnelly's not
wearing a wire you know what i mean
what's up everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes top 200 that
ain't too shabby
uh full hd video available on youtube
you can
uh subscribe there those numbers are
true to [ __ ] roof and also
patreon.com
uh you can sign up and get bonus content
of ayg you get bonus episodes
you can get episodes of hard feelings
which is being fully mixing it up [ __ ]
each other
airing some grievances a little bit
behind the curtain and then
for the top tier members we play ayg
with you guys every month in a live
stream you ask us questions we got two
questions we give away a hoodie
kind of um
none have been sent yet but they will be
sent on this uh it's patreon.com i'll
show you garbage guys
sign up today gang we love you and a
nice shout out to our producer
extraordinaire t-bone he is the magic
man he makes it all it makes us all look
pretty on here
um the pride of chicago comedy scene we
call him t-bone
but his mama named him toby mcmullen
hey what up boys got a hot one people
got one t-bone got a new mic stand over
there spending a little cash on t-bone
new mic stand new mic
save the money on hair kitty jokes
[Laughter]
and gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest here
was today it's a [ __ ] family up
so we're reading your questions right
here on the air
we could not be more happy to have our
our friend here with us today
if you haven't seen this episode go back
and check it the [ __ ] out
i think it was our first original one of
our first well the first
i think so yeah absolutely because our
backs were to the camera we were still
working we didn't have t-bone back then
we didn't have t-bone money back then
you know what i mean we still don't have
t-bone money for that
the s-t-bone t-bone doesn't have t-bone
gang he's the host of celebrate on
siriusxm do me a favor give me a nice
big round of applause for our good pal
member of the family here sean donnelly
everybody yes
fading away into nothing over there
stealing amazon packages
i talk about trish holy [ __ ] how much do
you want to just you want to arrest
all my citizens arrest those people when
i see that happen those are my favorite
videos
the ring doorbell videos where where
they where they catch
dirt bags stealing the packages you like
you like them getting away with it or
you like them
yeah the one lady that broke her leg
that was great and this fat guy comes
out he's wearing like a [ __ ] that's
why you liked it
you go betty even better the guy who
made the contraption you ever see the
guy who makes the contraption and they
steal the contraption
and then the alarm goes off and the
glitter sticks all over like a bait car
yeah it's like bay car but for amazon
packages i wish it was acid in there
in the face yeah anybody you steal
amazon i don't mind because amazon
replay don't even bat an eye
at it so you're not stealing they
replace it right away i'm not
i'm not condoning this but i'm also
saying
i've had packages stolen or whatever and
you call i just you it's a thing hey my
package never showed up and they go all
right and there's a new one on the way
yeah yeah and you get it but then you
realize when you get some of the stuff
on amazon you're like
those can afford it is what i'm saying
they can they can definitely afford it
and what you're getting is like garbage
half the time anyway
like dude it's a crap shoot you could
just end up with you could end up with
like a vibrator or a back pillow
you don't [ __ ] know what you're
getting you have no idea either
good times good times that's a party
right here
you get both of them some truly seltzers
and those two things and you get
called a [ __ ] day
buddy thank you so much for coming in
and sitting with us we're going to get
to a few patreon questions here
i'm sorry fan questions it's great let
them pick our brains a little bit you
look great by the way
thank you very much talking about you
you're losing weight you look fantastic
thank you you guys look angelic as well
you look amazing i
love you too there's something going on
with the cameras
or the jacket where people think that
i'm losing weight i
i which i have some confidence which i
didn't want it's not true by the way
they don't want to stop them but i have
within the past two weeks i've seen you
eat a salad so that might have
i've had a couple of salads you know
what i think does it for you also is
your haircut your haircut looks amazing
yeah
that's a great look for your hair thank
you so i think that makes you see your
your face
trying to [ __ ] yourself i want to [ __ ]
you in your janet jackson rhythm nation
jacket
i get behind him can you go like this
for me four
three two one very [ __ ] miami
are you are you a narcotics cop from 86.
yeah
look at that give me the cheeseburgers
now you pay your bills frank huh you pay
your bills
shout out to america you're getting it
you're one of the guys who shuts down
the drug dealers but also does the code
yes
at the same time those sleeves aren't
pushed up they're fully extended right
now
listen it's [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] in here
i'm [ __ ] schvitzen and
well you came in and put that jacket
that jacket stayed here you don't wear
you put a jacket on
of course it's my show jacket because
everyone's breaking my balls about
wearing my [ __ ]
my heavy fleece they say like homeless
dude also for a big guy i don't know if
it's selection when you get to the store
or not but the colors you choose are out
of this
that first ambitious that first round of
ads for the stereo app it was just me by
myself
yeah i had this thing on i was all
jacked up i'm like this thursday night
make sure you sign up
[Laughter]
you're peacocking and that's right i
don't do
i listen i'm significantly smaller than
you i'm i'm a
chubbier guy right and i wear all black
or earth tones this guy comes in with
like neon green neon yellow baby blue
show it off that's the other way to go
you can lean into it yeah you lean into
it and you get people that wear the big
the big boisterous stuff and then
it takes away from the chubbiness for
people they don't know what's going on
but only certain people can get away
with what's good what's going on with
that
because you have to own it while you're
doing and you're owning the shirt while
you're owning it that's right i [ __ ]
own it
[ __ ] owning it here no he leases it
he's gotta have a bathroom
that thing's back in two months why
don't they go keep it at the studio
it's property of ayg that jacket's got
his own room here
two other shows are wearing this but no
you look fantastic i was thinking before
we came in
we're all we're all irishmen yes here to
a degree
yeah and i was curious do you guys have
any are you starting to have any of the
shanty irish um afflictions that usually
come
like do you does anybody have gout you
have you you're starting to get excited
over the past six months i've over
quarantined i've developed eczema yeah
like
just some old irish guy yeah i have bad
skin now
dial soap are you whittling while you're
eating an onion you're just looking at
your eggs while you're just carving a
ship out of
adam's soap out of the potatoes that's
killed kennedy
things will never be the same yeah um
now i just i developed it over yeah how
does
that they know how it happened or no i
don't know because i'm wondering what's
irish trash
what do you mean i mean i'm dude i'm
just talking enough to be in a dirt ball
genetic garbage yeah the uh no i haven't
got gout yet but i was convinced
because we look like this show could be
called three guys with cows
like honestly it really could are you
gal yeah yeah
brought to you by so you think you can
get out
but no no gout yet but i just have you
know what's getting from me the old
irish man ear hair slash nose hair thing
yeah but that's not an affliction i
guess but it kind of
if you let it go it's not good it's bad
i think if you let it go it becomes like
that hardcore
coarseness that makes my [ __ ] it's the
kind of thing that you ever have the ear
hair and then
you you scratch it in your head and it
sounds like a dj in your ear
you never had that when you rub the ear
hair on your ear and it sounds like wait
wait no i'm not from the shire
yeah i had like long ear hair i had to
get a i had to get one of those ear hair
things
and i had to like take it out of my nose
and take it out of my ear oh all right
well this brings out i mean this is a
perfect segue into the first question
uh from patreon guys you know when you
sign up for patreon we'll automatically
answer your question we'll also answer
some from the facebook group those are
the two main ways
people are sending us message emails
those are the two best ways to do it
join the patreon
we'll definitely get a red and we also
pull facebook group this is from anthony
every year anthony ever use a car key to
clean the wax out of your ears
or anything else i've gotten in there
with a paper clip a couple of times
i've used a pen cap car key never
because i think there's so much
crap on car keys you're just you're just
adding to the wax a little bit i've used
car keys to
clean my sinuses out
you're like i use card keys as a cpap
machine i uh i've used it to clean my
nails i've used car keys to clean my
nails yeah it's like
like but it has to be a silver one they
look cleaner
how what how could you stick a key in
your ear and get anything
that's what i want how bad is your wax
build
no i think he's like it's not that bad
so you like kind of just
circle around i don't know i mean i'm
not a [ __ ] you're not an ent
i've never been a big ear wax guy to be
honest i don't really get it that's
that's surprising i get it when
the headphones give it to everybody so i
wear my headphones then i'll have a ton
of it right after i wear my headphones
and i'll use even q-tips which is such a
what they're saying is
don't now q-tips came out and said don't
put these in your ears it's like dude
you [ __ ] sold us on it for 30 years
and you take the supplies
that's like mcdonald's saying don't eat
big macs it's the same thing yeah get
the [ __ ] out which they're not
[Laughter]
but no one has said that um
but car keys no have you no no no way
but
what you've used pen cap i've used for
my nails and my ears sure yeah
uh but car key i don't see i've never
i've probably i've used it to open boxes
a car key that's not that's not
that trashy i guess yeah
um i use um i got to use a q-tip after
the shower that's part of my shower
routine same here
yeah on the same way which is growing by
the way which is annoying
the shower routine as you get older it
gets more and more
uh we've said this i think on hard
feelings or on the patreon i don't think
it's an age thing i think it's a size
thing for you there's a lot going on
there's a lot of wear and tear on that
body
i probably have more stuff what do you
what did you add to it can you give us
the list uh
well i don't know if we want this this
is gonna be a [ __ ]
nasty lesson i shove my car keys in my
pee hole
i have the foot scrubber thing in the
shower that's the first thing oh really
do you scrub my feet i get
out towel dry duty years i have to get
i got this shout out to [ __ ] gold
bond gold bond has
uh [ __ ] in the in the spray can now
really yeah spray on gold bond i had
i had oh dude i'm in there [ __ ]
tagging the [ __ ] out of myself i had a
mishap with
uh gold bond once i didn't realize
you're not supposed to put medicated
gold bond on your in your on your balls
did it burn is it like
wait yeah that's the whole point he said
medical i put medicated
yeah but goldblum is mad i want this no
no then it's then it's something i put
too much or something and i was walking
around all day i had to go home i was
like i was
i think i was like working somewhere and
i had to leave in the middle i go i
gotta go home for personal reasons
[Laughter]
i gotta get out of here i must have put
too much i think i just i was like
making cutlets down there you know what
i'm saying like i was i was like
powdering it like with my hand
and i think i just took way too much
like yeah
he was like lebron before the playoffs
it was like
it was like the most painful zeppelin
ever
a couple of deep fried oreos a couple of
funnel cakes down that bad boy
are you are you a gold bond guy you do
you pattern right now it's up until that
point i pout no i don't powder right now
but i go through phases so i'll bring
back powder
but i do i go all johnson's and
johnson's baby i go wait so right now
you get out of the shower there's no
powder
i dry because yeah really i use a blow
dryer
you know when i use it more than that
size thing maybe i just want i want
that's not
i've always done it i just like to make
sure everything he uses a blow dryer and
a team of eight
two of the neighbors come over nascar
pit crew
it's a pandemic you need a part-time job
just go for it the uh
no i use you know what i do it's
probably and tell me if it's the worst
for you
the summer time is when it's it's it's
peak summer
i have the bad the the in between i'll
i'll be on my phone too long or
something yeah in the middle and i
can't stand it i'll put powder on that
you need anti-chafing stick that's what
i got
is that what it is yep gold mom makes
you put it right in between your thighs
or in any crevice that you don't want to
get done i think it's official all
female listeners have tuned out
honey i'll be in there in a second i got
to put my cream on
but no car keys i feel like it's
hardcore that's like a new level
to get something out too that's crazy
i don't know i don't i mean yeah our
listeners are [ __ ] savages dude you
know
i mean they're listening they're they're
listening to are you garbage they're not
[ __ ]
they're not kennedy's so if he's asking
do you do that does that mean that he
does that yeah for sure yeah
yeah yeah um this is from kashan have
you ever taken a leak while brushing
your teeth
oh yeah yes i can't it's too much moving
oh i think you just kind of go at a
slower rate so you're kind of like
that's like rubbing your head and pat
your thumb i can't do it i'm not
that's why i'm not a good drummer i
can't keep two templates
do you have to keep one hand on the pee
pee while you're peeing
have to what do you mean like do you
have to keep one hand on your wee wee to
keep it pointed in the right direction
or will it hang down and pee otherwise
then i have to you got a small dick
what's the deal
yeah i think we've gone over that i got
the irish curse yeah no but i'm just
saying
i can but you have to look to yeah you
have to make sure you're
[ __ ] because i could see if you had
to hold one hand and do that you
couldn't do
not like peeling back [ __ ] fat
[Laughter]
like just now this starts moving like i
can't do
two different temperatures i did so i
got i'm like [ __ ] you know i think
i'm doing it but it's a half-assed brush
i'm not doing a
full brush when i'm peeing and i've
probably only done it a couple of times
i'm not doing it you brush your teeth in
the shower
no i've never done that yeah it's trash
i've been i've been peeing in the shower
lately oh that was the next question do
you pee in the shower yeah no i never
hit for the are you garbage cycle and
peed in the shower while brushing your
teeth in the shower that's i mean wow
i have that's just then you're just an
assassin
it's a pretty warm feeling it's probably
the closest thing to doing heroin you
could probably
get it's just it feels you've worked
peeing in a warm shower
while your shower's coming down over top
are people not paying in the shower
that's crazy to me i'm not
i don't pee in the shower you know i
love it i i heard about the ring worm
thing i don't pee in the shower you get
ring worms
i've been painting the shower every day
34 years i have ring worms what kind of
[ __ ] irish tails
are you even being told at night why
don't you be peeing in the shower
i was on a ship ring where you told me
about ringworm and the sea monster
that's what wrestlers get i don't get
that from people you can get that from
stepping on p
and this maybe it's not your own pee but
it's maybe it's maybe that's the thing
you can't get the other people out with
your people why do you think people go
to
their college dorms they wear flip-flops
into the shower because that's like 50
guys using the shower
but then what's the difference then well
like if it's like you if you're in your
you live how many dudes you get rolling
through there
[Laughter]
a couple of guys coming in i think
you're fine i've never had it
oh okay i've never done it i never did
it give it a whirl go home tonight give
it a whirl
i've had ringworm it's all pipes it's
all pipes i think i just feel the shower
would be gross after i did it or
something
and i'm not dainty at all but for some
reason i don't do that
great feeling let it go dude yeah is it
great yeah
i'll do it in the tub i don't care do
you feel like you're just you're like
just going against society you feel like
you're on heroin like the warm waters
rushing over your
over your back and pee's coming out of
you it's great you either got really bad
heroin or you pee
really good i don't turn off in the
shower one or the other because they
ain't the same
could be in the shower they've got some
bad i have some bad h
i've joked off in the shower definitely
oh i did that this morning did you
yeah i love what work dude sign me up
i'm
yeah you have in your own apartment now
you all over the place with that
i what do you mean it's like the
honeymoon in there oh no
well no it's no because it's covered
it's very hard i know
yeah yeah i'm all ever since i got
blinds too that was
once i got blinds it was a [ __ ]
free-for-all way to like get my blinds
you son of a [ __ ]
that's how trash i am i didn't have
blinds and my landlords were like we're
going to get you blind
they bought blinds for the house and
they were like donnelly guy i ain't
playing ball
i'm like i'm literally jerking off my
living room like huddled down on the
couch so nobody's
too low i'm basically doing this stop
drop and roll but for jerking off
he's under the couch and you're just
praying no one can see you like
if i can't see them they can't see me
right meanwhile someone's on the roof
just like
look at this [ __ ] that's like a felony
now they'll come and get if you're in
your house
you don't think if you live across from
a school maybe yeah yeah
exactly what do you think we moved there
for vacationing without jeffrey epstein
maybe
um all right this is uh wait we're just
on the same [ __ ]
uh great question love it
yeah um this is pretty funny that's not
the first time that question came up on
the show right
i think it might be that's interesting
i don't think so to be honest with you i
mean maybe in like in quick passing i
know we've discussed
not really wiping and hopping in the
shower when you're done pooping i've
done that
you have something that you feel like
you're cheating the system on that one
yeah
yeah you're making deals because you're
like i save all that toilet paper
are those wipes um this is from the
savage cabbage anybody in your family
pronounced the word italian as italian
yes no no long island they don't do that
no
no it's i think it's italian yeah i've
always heard italian
attack yeah we uh italy italy hitler
john italy is that just an accent thing
though i think it's just a dirty feeling
but then chicago's italian right they
say italian in chicago
only if you got something bad to say
about them
[Laughter]
it's never in a proper way no you got
you got beef with baked ziti
is the trashiest of all the italian
dishes but we weren't like to go on
record
basically is the one that like broke out
from the rest of the italians
will have every even an irish vfw hall
gets together
um let's get lasagna that's like we were
saying growing up uh
i think it was in the uh yeah just fake
ass lasagna [ __ ]
trying to face yourself but you're right
though just have a lasagna
it's always like they got to tell you
how simple it is to make it it's easy
just make the noodles
yeah i know it sucks lady yeah that's
why i didn't [ __ ] make it myself
that's also why they don't make the
lasagna because they're like i'm not
it's too much
time to put a little [ __ ] time and
effort into it it's so true it's gonna
be so easy
how easy how easy is every single
[ __ ] time
how many times i've had like an ant
explain to me how good is how easy it is
to make ziti
it's like yo buttered noodles or hit the
bricks
wasted yeah boiled noodles put some
cheese and sauce threw in the oven
watched oprah [ __ ] the mailman
and pulled it out yeah we get it
um all right this is uh yeah that was
italians
this is for shawnee you're a bit of a
you know bit of a drinker have been
that's how
he likes a gun that's a listener that's
how me and donnelly are [ __ ]
donnelly's like my one of my go-to
drinking guys i look very hemingway
right now too by the way you have to
watch
yeah yeah that's my goat i'm gonna write
a novel very florida
you're a very florida keys vibe right
now oh thank you just
you have like kind of like boat captain
and going
he's got his good double pocket shirt on
i have a show tonight this is the shirt
i'm wearing this is like nice for me
this is actually a christina knight
yes we are drinking pals yeah absolutely
um
one of the greatest we drinking one of
the greatest bars i've ever been to in
my life yeah it's on
it's there's there's like a romance
because we get there and like they don't
close like they'll let us stay
and it's just [ __ ] shawn anytime
anytime you try to leave at any time
you'll be like are you going
you're like hey sean i'm leaving you
guys you're leaving
it could be like [ __ ] noon the next
day
you're like covered in blood i'm like i
gotta get a lot
you're leaving
people some people got very get very
scared when i think
besides anxiety
and sometimes he gets you know i like to
leave early gang real quick let's talk
about the brand new live show
happening over there on the stereo app
of ru garbage we're going to be
taking your questions live on the air
yeah guys you get to join the
conversation on the stereo app it's
going to be me and the big man
chopping it up you guys get to jump in
with your questions we'll go over them
live on the air on the stereo app and
we're going to be doing this
every thursday for the next couple of
weeks
get involved it's going to be a good
time it's easy just go to the link in
the description of this episode
the link is stereo.com kevinryan or
stereo.com
h foley and when you click that link and
sign up for the stereo app
me and a big man get to wet our beaks a
little bit
everybody wins so join this join the
stereo app join the conversation
join ru garbage baby 100 free sign up
today
now back to the show you don't like he's
you're the dude
like you get you guys you're the worst
you used to be such a good hank you
stink anymore
i used to be i'm surprised i mean like
back in the day when we were like drink
like
the land in the village and stuff you
were a good hang you'd be drinking and
telling jokes and
dude now you're like why is that guy
looking at me why is that bartender not
serving me what's donny's deal i gotta
get out of here
i got your car i got the thing i got the
man you but you do
you leave you do leave early now yeah
you do that because i think i had a
couple late nights with you and
i'm 45. i'm 42. yeah
all right and also we're not even doing
it right now so that's when we do it we
go all out
we did we did a paddy's outdoor thing
and we got a little bit toasty and then
got even more toasty after yeah exactly
so
fantastic um i've always my parents have
always been that
family we've always left early yeah so
what's interesting
i think you're talking dorks that's what
i mean we're partying over here
my you hear this [ __ ] the foley's
leave right before the check gets
dropped
they just did last call terry get your
bag
[Laughter]
terry mike's looking at a dessert menu
let's go stretching the arms while
you're pushing the check over
all right we had a great time with you
guys
thanks so much i still hope that plays
on camera that was fantastic
that was great we had a good time with
you guys
no not that not never at dinner just
like by like parties
we i don't know i don't know we got
anxiety what do you mean
we gotta relax have a drink but you but
you do you used to hang out later when
he used to hang out later
you're saying well we were doing a lot
of shows like in the village we're doing
a lot of shows with the lantern and
stuff and like we'd have like an
eight a ten and a midnight and then like
you know after the ten you start booze
and drink
right right we were hanging or i was
outside smoking everything's hanging
now he's like i'm gonna dude literally
you have you have the
look and demeanor of a person and how
much i like you i want you to hang out
longer right you know what i'm saying
and you have the
look out of a guy who does hang out
until five in the morning yeah right
doesn't he
yes anxiety is too bad it's too much the
next time you're hanging out
have you ever gotten like me for me like
making you feel weird about leaving did
you get mad at me from doing that
like back not man it just gives me
anxiety
everything gives you anxiety dude you're
giving me anxiety
and for me to stay late let's be honest
i need to procure some
accessories all right let's put it that
way i'm not good just drinking
i get tired i get drunk oh okay i see
what you're saying okay yeah yeah yeah
you need to you need a a pick me up
sure yeah yeah i got you but you said
you you stuck the bar like you know
they're about to raid the place
if you sit there you're like nah just
the cranberry juice for me like
[ __ ] killing everybody he's a [ __ ]
informant he's like he's ratting on
everybody
if foley cleans his ear with car keys on
the night out he starts hearing real
fast
his business his ears get some business
plans yeah you get out of there like
you're wearing a wire
i know i don't like you abracadabra
he jumps over the bar
xanax relax will you a couple of guys
trying to hang out over here
i have a snake bite will you i'm telling
the story over i'm i'm just reading
kevin are just dranking
fully comes over here so what do you
hear about that shipment coming in
say it in my chest will you
the boss say anything to you
can you still give me those tickets what
are you talking about folly
good times huh um but this is uh
so that that all stemmed from this is
from ryan uh have you ever used
uh something to stare a drink that
wasn't a spoon or a straw
oh yeah when you're like drinking with
your buddies at a house or something
butter knife
uh probably a pen a pan we did like in
the dorm room or something
yeah a pen was big but i'm also your
fingers always do you ever have someone
make you one
stare it with their finger then give it
to you yeah what yeah that's
that's a lot of my family parties my own
goes like this is good right i'm like
yeah sure let's do it i don't give a
[ __ ] your nails floating yeah it's
whiskey ain't it it'll kill whatever's
in there yeah it's alcohol yeah sure
it's like like i think the barber shop
the barber side
did you guys growing up did you guys in
your like little bar set up
in your family home wherever that was or
we didn't have one whenever it came out
yeah yeah did it ever come out for
parties
because we used to put the bar on top of
the washer and dryer you're not putting
the bar and
you were putting two liters in a [ __ ]
bottle of washer and popcorn
stop calling in a bar it was a bottle of
maraschino cherries
there was some cut up lime juice you
know what i mean
we put the [ __ ] uh tablecloth over
it exactly
yeah it's a bowl exactly a bowl with an
ice in it yeah we've talked about this
my parents always lancers wine which was
always like this red bottle do you
remember this red bottle of wine i think
it was like cheap wine
but they love it it's coming from your
family it was for sure
no one's pegging you as i go let me get
a savvy on
now i saw her home or nothing are you
saying my parents weren't some onions
do our parents because because i have
that your mom drinks
sh you know tasty wine yeah that's what
my whole family calls it nicie wine and
what's neesee want it's uh like fruit
wine it's pinot it's cavett pinot grigio
it's like
you know a nickel for a [ __ ] 55
gallon jug holy [ __ ] so do you think
they really is that boxed sorry is that
no no it's in a ball we're not animals
we got a little bit of cake you can get
it in the box
yeah at the manufacturer's request
don't act like you can't get a box you
can't get them yeah what does your mom
drink coors lights
this is the the the i always thought i
don't know if i mentioned this last
i think i did actually the budweiser
midges the little we call them ponies
i love a pony yeah yeah go get some
rolling rock ponies a bucket of ponies
at a nice sports bar
good night that's a shot [ __ ] just
ice
cold they're great yeah whacking ponies
no but i was gonna say do you think our
pet like do they really
like that one like you're saying like my
parents loved it did they really love it
or
did they just get used to it because it
was so cheap i think they liked it i
remember
they liked it but they like it because
that's what they're used to drinking
because it's cheap like
like yeah i think it's like a it's like
so that's what their tastes are you know
it's a chicken or an egg yeah exactly
yeah it's like yeah this isn't bad we
can afford it oh i like it
yeah it's a taste of it cause there's a
lot of that to this day my mom puts
we're also
irish yaks from long island my mom puts
ice in her wine
she puts ice in it and red wine and and
white
i don't think it matters i don't think
it matters so people think that's like
blasphemous for wine
you can't do that to wine but on the
island i'm sure on the island it's it's
on the menu
[Laughter]
it's 50 cents actually a [ __ ]
delicacy
on the island it's on the menu rocco use
the good ice tonight
give me the good ice tonight not the
cube stuff
uh wine with crushed ice just having a
wine slurpee oh
wow that brings up this this is for
michael uh would your family put
cases or 12 packs of beers and soda
outside on the porch during like a
thanksgiving or crisp like not in a
cooler just outside because it was cold
out yes on the back down 100
yeah my that means to do with alcohol is
my dad had
vintage vintage seltzers also like
seltzers
and cokes and everything everything yeah
in the background yeah outside and the
garage
like on the side yeah vintage like this
is the brand
that was a that's like that's a trashy
seltzer brand that
really is cents probably really
surprised you were just name dropping
vintage
i'm stunned i thought that's what you
meant i'm like
i got all my money in vintage shelter
our cellar was filled with uh
they were all in those canisters that
the clowns had they sprayed each other
with that's
you know it's with the gun but you're
racist celsius
oh man that's true uh this is from gary
do all your bathroom towels
no of course not what no no you mean
when i was growing up and now i don't
think i've ever that's ever happened
oh growing up yeah we had one set of
showtiles that you couldn't touch
you touched those towels but i mean like
[ __ ] no i think you mean like you're all
if you got out of the shower and your
mom got out of the shower did those two
towels match
no some of them did yeah but not all of
them they weren't all the same we're not
throwing out pals what are we [ __ ]
[ __ ] well that's kind of the point
like
that's the idea it's like yeah they're
[ __ ] three bucks you can throw them
out yeah we also have we had a beach
towel that had freaking that
literally was look it looked like
pantyhose stretched apart
you could see through it through it and
we'd still have it they wouldn't throw
it away we never
i would use it like a [ __ ] idiot no i
do we're the same way but here's the
thing
those towels i like a towel when it's
all worn down
no but then they get tested because
you've never had a new one they get a
new one then talk to me okay
this is what he does he justifies his
dirt no
is different i'm not saying like take it
right off the shelf you need a little
bit of grit on that
it takes a little while it's not just
one watch it takes a few washes okay
right
okay it doesn't take like two football
seasons no get out of here
you're nuts but but i'll say this but
but like i said it gets to a point that
it doesn't pick up any of the water
because it's basically a giant blue
sleeve piece of paper yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're just moving it around yeah
just moving around yeah exactly i love
it
i might as well use paper towel like
paper towels probably had more
absorbability
than that one towel that beach towel
dude my roommate my roommate flipped
growing
in college or whatever like he would
like not have a towel or whatever and he
would
sometimes you would dry off using paper
towels i'm like dude take a t-shirt or
something
he would just be like with the bat i'm
like dude that was [ __ ] three bucks i
just bought that roll of paper towel
yeah because you
use like 80 of you're them saving
anything like here's
just buy yourself a towel i remember
looking at them like an animal i'm like
dude
i i'll use a dirty t-shirt or a soccer
so i'm like this is savagery
that's tracy i've used the t-shirt to
dry off with it i didn't forget i had
worked
i forgot i didn't know for a year i'll
do that now let me sidebar here how do
you feel and i know this isn't good for
the pipes
how do you feel about wiping with a
paper towel
what i'll do it yeah i have no i it's
weird i have no pro i have no problem
doing it if i have
it no i don't prefer it i would say i
prefer it you prefer it prefer it more
grip that's a man's man right there
on the job site is that where you prefer
it uh oh
you you more my ass with a hand towel
it's you know what it is it keeps more
distance between you
and the materials you can get a little
more you get in there a little more with
you
get some more stuff good grip sometimes
i've even done it you ever do it
you're in a pinch and you and it's like
it's like the
the school paper towels like the the
hard ones the hard
brown ones those things are shoe boxes
yeah i've wiped
those nails that's brutal that's like i
don't leave your blood that's like
playing basketball and dress shoes
[Laughter]
fully wipes with paper towels and he
dries with a shop vac
yeah shout out to a good shop
i always wanted to have like we've
posted pictures of it they posted
pictures in the facebook group
where it's that one unit it's like a a
sink a toilet and a shower all in one
thing i always wanted to like the the
jetsons version
like where you just would go through a
little conveyor belt and everything just
happens at once
yeah you come all out yeah sound like a
real go-getter
can i stand here and someone performs on
my body
[Laughter]
well i don't mind that like after like i
don't that one thing i'll say is i don't
know if this is even trashy or not
the beach showers are great you're
talking about it all the time
the outdoor shower that's a great uh
sensation too because you're in the hot
weather and the cold water yeah it's
fantastic it feels good
big outdoor shower guy when i landscaped
in the summer
uh we would be around poison ivy so much
that we'd always have a thing of uh palm
olive or something
there's one of those soaps that if you
washed off with it it killed the grease
and
really yeah so and when you got out of
there we immediately would like take
showers into people's backyard just you
know
with our shorts on or whatever yeah um
and take a shower with [ __ ] dish
washing soap ride back feeling clean as
a whistle like your jewels winfield in
pulp fiction
gentlemen you both in the county
exactly um all right this is uh this is
actually from the facebook group this is
from manny
uh do you or does anyone in your family
have an old couch on your front porch or
outside anywhere back porch garage we're
not the duke boys what
well if my friend front porch or front
lawn you're saying front porch
on porch like you know oh as the seating
as the seat no
no no that's some real that seems like a
like a down
home south kind of when you don't care
about the property value
yeah well we would do it growing up
garage it was like we were sure
oh we gotta crash in the you gotta couch
in the garage oh but it's like an old
couch that you like moved out you're
like oh the kids will
sit on this in the ground i think we did
that at one point yeah
yeah we did that but i think i told you
this i don't know if i said this last
time
but then then it got to the point where
my dad's friend bob lolly stored his
boat in our garage and it didn't fit
it's stuck out of the garage did i tell
you guys that
i think so yeah so wait you have you can
have a
girl you had that the front the front of
the boat sticking out of here
sticking out of your thing all winter oh
for for like 20 years the donnelly's
must be doing pretty well
yeah that's probably what that's knocked
they got a boat they got a caprice
classic and a boat in their garage
at least they don't have a couch on the
front yeah right well i think that is
like because i think you might have
mentioned this too but i have like
relatives that would keep christmas
lights all year round
i never understood that that's trash in
the backyard
you know now it's kind of okay to have
christmas lights in the backyard
if you're entertaining entertaining
but if you just got them up and you're
not turning them off that's trashy and
i'm not even talking about the one i'm
talking about the colorful
bowl yeah you're not mistaking these
things for just entertaining
this isn't a luau this is like this
should be december these things only
show themselves it's no one's engagement
party exactly
exactly it's not a lumineers video
[Laughter]
dude that's a [ __ ] great joke
lumineersvid
donnelly's hot today folks killing um
all right this is from augustine this is
also a drinking one how do you drink
your beer at home or in a restaurant
if like if you're at a restaurant and
they serve you it's in a bottle and they
serve you a glass do you pour into the
glass
no no i don't no i drink it on the
bottle yeah i prefer the bottle
you i think or sometimes sorry but
sometimes it depends on the
beer but like unless it's like again or
something that we're
needing yeah yeah so no otherwise it's a
if you order like a budweiser and they
bring you a glass out of the bottle a
bottle
out of the bottle yeah i always be a
real dirtball because i thought you
meant like how fast because i usually
when i get the first one oh first
i put it down it doesn't stand a chance
because i want to get into the zone
oh is that what it is oh yeah i chopped
my face he's going home by nines
[Laughter]
[ __ ] cliff notes
one of my first beers i'm saying my
goodbyes hey guys so i'll see you let me
get another beer before i go
he's boofing whiskey uh
i like a nice draft yeah but i'm saying
you're getting no bobby
you have to get in the bottle yeah
they're serving it with a glass
if it's an ipa i'm pouring in a glass if
it's like a budweiser corona or
something light
i'm keeping it in the bottle long as
it's nice and cold yeah yeah
i'll be cold that's another thing a
frosted glass you can't beat no
but at a restaurant frosted glass in
your own home you ever have those oh
yeah i do because
i do the guinness cans i only do
guinness cans the nitro cans or with the
thing in it the bottles stink and i do
and i put my
real irish glass in the freezer and i
have a cold
cold guinness in the i drink anything
else out of that out of that glass
yeah yeah yeah but chocolate milk
oh dude i love it pulling out a frosted
glass with some milk oh it's fantastic
oh i got i went on a zoom date with a
girl like i don't know a few months ago
yeah right yeah talk about lothario but
but
and i did uh oreos and milk
in that in that same glass and that in
that pint glass and she said oh
oh a white guy drinking milk it's too
gross
and i'm like all right this was fun i'll
see you i'll see you later i was like
what are you talking about i don't care
she thought like
the idea of like the wholesomeness of
the milk and that i was like
i was like it was almost like a little
house in the prairie or something like
drinking milk is a
weird old-timey thing and i was like
yeah you're out of your [ __ ] mind hit
the brick sweetheart this is a milk
household okay
i don't know about that but i also i
mean i'm the roma i'm the romance legend
but
like listen milk and oreo's on a date
what are you doing
[Laughter]
you started out with a glass of red wine
soon saw it going south
[Laughter]
i have caviar and wine and then i see i
said we talked for 10 minutes i'm like
let me get those oreos in there
grab the fritos back in the fridge
um all right let's see here this is uh
this is from daniel
ever invite someone with you somewhere
because you know they will offer to pay
for you too
no but i'm always excited when it
happens
[Laughter]
uh no i've never done it on purpose i've
never done a purpose
but but i maybe i would because i would
never
be aiming for the exp the explicit
reason no
i mean yeah that's what they mean that's
what they mean but no i've done it where
i'm friend and then if you have a friend
that's like no i got you like that
yeah exactly i've had that happen i have
a lot of friends that i know that if
they're there they're gonna be like i
got like
yes or yeah you know what i mean but you
wouldn't you want to hang out with them
yeah because they're getting it you know
what i mean but no i'm not getting it
but what he's saying is like for the
only reason they're there is because
they're going to pay for them
yeah i've never done that if i may step
in kevin's never had to put himself in
that situation
because he has a very strong support
system especially
especially in his lean years all of his
buddies had good jobs
so yeah when i was coming off all my
friends you know i mean i would have you
made your living at that
at what yeah go so jealous dude this is
like the third time you brought it up in
three episodes
even on the bench you're so jealous you
lived a certain life of comfort that's
all
no then i didn't how much of a comfort
could you live just by going out for a
couple dinners are you mean it would be
a concert no
no so am i out of out of the this is
what he's talking about trash finishes
go to a restaurant i don't get to do
that yeah sorry i have friends and i
hang out buddies
they all got cash and do well yeah so
when i was started when i would start a
comedy all my friends were like starting
in like finding
lawyers or whatever so like they all
have cash so i'd be like and like they
would always listen to like our pods or
whatever so they knew i was broke and
whatever so they would just you know
offer to pay yeah i got it you got trips
out of it no
no yeah i know i know people that got
trips out of that stuff oh wow
he's not a goumaj
[Laughter]
are you a 19 year old russian girl
[Laughter]
can you put your head between your legs
we get to miami beach watching the
trotters
but also my cousin uh
my lap of luxury you mean i'm sorry all
my cousins are there's like another
social circle and i was always the
youngest by like 10 years so don't put
down a card
so like i always grow up i was always
the kid yeah
it's like my brother my sister i have
like 15 20 cousins where i was the
youngest so they're all like
even if i did have money out to pay they
wouldn't even let you do it yeah
i had that hat with my cousins the
foley's don't open tabs we pay as we go
yeah of course you're going to run out
in a minute's notice no you got to be
ready
you got to be ready to jump what if
there's a hot case
yeah i got to go to man
i'm not jealous i was just pointing it
out yeah but you make pointing it out
you pointed it out multiple times and
the way you do it the way you said it
was like you were like all right so this
guy
sorry i have family and friends that
love me i'm not a weirdo with no friends
i apologize because it's funny
it's a connotation how he said kevin's
kevin's kippy's friends yeah but you
guys are friends so he's like we're not
friends
hanging out well he doesn't hang out
what are you talking about in good
hanging
guys are friends i've hung out with you
socially more in the past
year than i have with him not at all
time
you guys were you guys he doesn't yeah
we haven't we don't hang
no we don't have that's also life stuff
i don't hang out with anybody either i'm
just saying pandemic
but pandemic every time we meet up
you're like where's foley i'm like i
went home
yeah yeah i do do that yeah yeah i do my
work and i go home
for me it's just my wife and my child
this guy's on his [ __ ] high horse um
all right this is from jamie oh before
the record it does it did sound like you
were jealous of his 100 percent
i'm not an ass i'm well aware
the emotional gymnastics he does i don't
i don't i don't blame you it sounds like
a nice little life it's yeah it sounds
nice
he also like what am i going to be like
no i'm not going to kiss he used to be
like i got no money like i got no money
i'm like what are you doing i'm going
down to philly
and then monday ah we were here we were
there
yeah yeah people like to have me around
i'm sorry people can't say the same for
you
little orphan kippy had some [ __ ]
daddy warbucks situation going on
yeah man what do you want from me
meanwhile i'm [ __ ] in southie
sleeping on a couch
outside all right this is from chad do
you eat like regularly do you eat
non-breakfast foods for breakfast
um hold on that's a great fun that's
okay that's a whole run of a question
and the answer is yes you're because
you're a weirder weirder food guy
yeah asthma as i'm this happened for
years like i
i i haven't i've only eaten eggs for
three years
that's crazy so i would i would every
day like at breakfast time i would have
lunch food every chicken
chicken farm cereal i always have sides
of beef at 10 in the morning
i'll take the pork chops and orange
juice please
can you give me a souffle for breakfast
that's the soup today
but no yeah i absolutely would do that
absolutely
sometimes mostly sandwiches like chicken
sandwiches
yeah if you're having a chicken sandwich
for the first meal of the day there's
something
like in the morning in the a.m i would
never eat when i
i would push lunch i push i would push
lunch up to like 11. i was eating
i first needed 11. now that with my
situation i'm eating at 12 and i'm
eating lunch and i'll have breakfast
foods at 12 because i make myself eggs
when you were working a regular job what
was your last regular job my last
regular job is i worked at an
advertising place and
facilities working facilities and
advertising but a corporate job you got
to be there at like 9 00 a.m nine a.m so
there what i would probably do there is
either i would eat like
shitty breakfast food so it'd be like a
roll or it'd be like doughnuts
but then a lot of the time i would wait
till i'd wait to lunch and eat lunch
sean's so true
[Laughter]
that's a european thing too you get a
pound of sugar in a butter roll
yeah one of those one of those wheel
things
i need 10 cents worth of shoelaces
pipe tobacco back one of those stick
candies with a swirl
[Laughter]
yo let me get a roll in some unfiltered
lucky springs i don't get it
i mean i get it it's a it's not a philly
cough no
[ __ ] there's nothing in it it's a dinner
roll yeah it's a slice of jelly
something oh yeah that but that was
buttermilk a butter bagel yeah butter
you're not having a bagel you're not
you're not a lighter roll
i mean a lighter bagel a roll is a
dinner food
you go out to dinner they give you a
dinner roll they give you rolls where
they give you bread with dinner you're
not getting enough you're not getting a
blender's bagel at dinner
a kaiser roll in the morning butter
kaiser on the morning
is it breakfast lund's bagels are great
yeah
um shout out to the lenders that caught
everybody
that was the showstopper because we were
all we were on the low like
yes would you would you guys freeze them
or would you keep them
goddamn right of course one time i went
over my buddy's house they were just on
the counter i'm like
hey dust those get the ones out of these
in the freezer stack
they feel real weird when they're not
frozen they're like sponges
give me presses in the packaging we're
losing them
i don't trust them i only know them
frozen [ __ ] get those things on ice
mom don't hate touch you want to get
these on the rocks
good showstopper um i've only got a
couple of minutes left
wait what was that question oh the
non-breakfast
yeah thanks for tuning in
lenders you got lenders bagels on the
brain you know i also this might be
pulling back the curtain a little bit
i think over the last few weeks i forgot
what the family episodes are about
because i i realize i've been jumping
and answering these are questions that
that
that the fans want to ask the guest the
guest should always be answering first
oh but they also want to ask if it's all
different questions they want to ask you
too true but i feel like i've now
found a read i think you're overthinking
that it's a conversation starter
for us to talk about lenders i think i
think you're having some of your bar
anxiety right now
yeah that's exactly what's happening
wait who's asking me what
i'm sorry i answered your question for
mr donnelly i apologize i'll tell you
right now
me and kevin did not even think that
even once the whole entire time
i love you i love you so much it helps
me to re-angle the show gives me a uh
yeah this is an off-air topic why are
you doing it hey it's been a great
episode let me tell you right now
let me let me play a real pool i
completely forgot for a couple of weeks
that i'm a goober all right let's
all right all right go ahead um let's
see here what are we at
uh yeah shawnee's gotta go you gotta go
uh i wish
this is from dan uh have you ever put a
radio bumper sticker on your car or a
family's car
absolutely what radio station 92.7 wdre
it was the alternative
station in in long island you lost
confidence in that yeah
was it on your car or your family's car
it was on my it was on my family's car
with my sister but my sister was driving
it
so my sister probably put it on but i i
maybe i did i and i had
to think it was cool i thought it was so
cool yeah absolutely you never did you
are long
we were a non-bumper sticker household
of course it wouldn't be tons of bumpers
it wasn't like we were covered i don't
it was a one-off
like radio that seemed totally normal to
me radio station bumper stickers
you're trash i mean i guess
obviously not multiple and then we never
had the the things like get off my ass
or this and
we're all [ __ ] yes yeah yeah whatever
like it was always just like
irish trash i think it was only radio
station once that was all it was but not
even a lot of them just just the one
it's probably an awesome radio station
too great radio station yeah
90s alternative very famous or famous
around the country for being an
alternative station radio stations used
to be
the local radio station that was cool
used to be awesome they used to
make the summer and also i'm shocked you
never did this because
a lot of the reasons people did that is
because if they saw you with it on there
that you could win [ __ ] even trashier
what are you talking about i realized
that as i was saying
no no no you can win a free t-shirt way
out the door you drop some
dirt bag logic like that how am i
supposed to win journey tickets your
[ __ ] ass
i thought i had you oh man i totally
thought i [ __ ] got you i was sitting
there like what
are you gonna win the contest if you
don't have the sticker that was real
cute that was like that was like a
bigger kid holding a little kid's head
and he was trying to swing to hit him
and we got two free tickets to great
adventure to the dirt ball family
driving around in the 84 caprice shout
out to the donnelly's with the boat
hanging out of the garage
that guy remember that i told you this
but it got stolen and used a robbery at
a king cullen supermarket oh the boat
no the car the car they stole they stole
the car
they didn't get very far they got caught
ahoy matey
guy give me all the money stock up on
lenders bagels
ah gang what an episode shoney thank you
mustard thank you guys
well i definitely have you back as soon
as possible yeah we love having you here
we love the family yeah it's a good time
keep the questions coming uh anything
you want the folks out there to know
before you split right down the barrel
yes sir right here i will say uh yes
please follow me at shawneetime on
instagram and twitter that's
s-c-a-n-y-t-i-m-e
and also i have a podcast called the dyn
podcast it's movies and more and it's a
lot of fun so please
subscribe listen and rate and review and
all that jazz what everybody tells you
in this world yes siree bob thank you
very much kippy what do you got for him
uh guys as always please make sure you
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube subscribe there as well and
then patreon.com you get bonus content
and uh it's a good [ __ ] time also
follow me on all social media at
kevinryancomedy
excellent at age foley on ice on twitter
and foldygrams on instagram
and we'll see you next week peace
that was a blast gang real quick let's
one more time talking about the old
stereo app we could not be more excited
to have ru garbage
being a part of this fantastic new way
to interact with you guys
yeah guys quick reminder every thursday
for the next couple of weeks we're going
to be on the stereo app
answering your questions live it's easy
download the stereo app the link is in
the description
it's stereo.com kevinryan or stereo.com
h foley we get to wet our beaks it's
going to be a good time and get involved
baby and it's 100 free and 100 live
so check us out and join us every
thursday night see you there